[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques pour
notre pays et sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation historiquement la
puissance des pays occidentaux
permettait d'imposer les produits de
l'entreprise chez eux et dans leur zone
d'influencé
mais cette situation a évolué depuis les
années 70 avec la suppression ou la
réduction des droits de douane entre les
pays dans des zones où sur la planète
promu par l'organisation mondiale du
commerce la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation les pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale très violentes et je
dirais même brutal fait pourquoi nombre
d'entreprises appuyés par leurs états
n'hésite pas à employer tous les moyens
pour gagner des parts de marché ou
bloquer la concurrence
soyons clairs dans la guerre économique
comme le disait churchill d'une certaine
manière il n'y a pas d'amis tous les
coups sont permis car la signature ou le
renouvellement d'un contrat donne aux
vainqueurs de l'emploi dans la durée une
capacité d'investissement et bien
entendu des ressources financières
nous savons depuis le chinois zhu zhu
qui est l'auteur de l'art de la guerre
enfin plus exactement de la guerre des
états du nord qui a été écrit six
siècles avant jésus-christ nous savons
que le bon renseignement et la clusaz la
victoire le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
et on peut l'obtenir de matière légale
par l'intelligence économique en
exploitant toutes les opportunités
offertes par l'énorme quantité
d'informations qui sont à notre
disposition aujourd'hui mais bien
entendu aussi de manière illégale par
l'espionnage industriel
il est indéniable que la volonté de
transparence et le développement rapide
des nouvelles technologies de recherche
et de stockage des informations facilite
l'usagé de l'intelligence économique
aujourd'hui 90 à 95% les informations
existant sur l'ensemble de la planète
sont disponibles pour ceux qui savent
les chercher qu'il s'agisse de bilan de
brevets de fichiers clients ou de tout
autre chose
notons qu on les classe c informations
ses renseignements selon leurs
difficultés d'obtention en information
blanches c'est-à-dire accessible à tous
grise qui exige d'aller fouiller dans
les profondeurs du web à le diplôme et
les noirs qui sont celles que l'on garde
secrète
alors bien entendu l'espionnage
économique concerne la partie noire
contrairement à l'intelligence
économique qui s'occupe du reste
ajoutons que la difficulté majeure pour
les techniciens pour les spécialistes et
de distinguer les véritables
informations de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les fake news en effet et
c'est là où c'est compliqué celles ci
peuvent être de vraies informations que
regus rester secrète
souvenez-vous des conversations entre
hillary clinton et son directeur de
campagne
ça peut être aussi des inventions total
et on le voit tout le temps des
histoires farfelues qui sortent mais
compte que certains arrivent à croire et
puis ce qui est le plus efficace
un mélange des deux l'espionnage
industriel physique et tout autre chose
parce qu'il s'appuie sur des échanges
avec des connaisseurs du dossier ou des
actions qui sont menées au sein même des
entreprises ou encore à l'extérieur
ouvert le personnel et cette
collaboration volontaire ou involontaire
de proches et de salariés de la cible
est au coeur de ces pratiques ou être
plus clair elle s'acquiert par le
chantage ou l'adhésion en jouant sur
quatre critères clés l'argent
l'idéologie légaux et la compromission
ce que les anglo-saxons appellent dans
le jargon maïs
l'expérience montre malheureusement
qu'il n'y a pas de citadelle imprenable
aujourd'hui la pénétration physique sur
les sites pour récupérer des documents
ou des produits est en diminution par
suite de la numérisation de pratiquement
tous les domaines d'activité et c'est
pourquoi elle est progressivement
remplacé par des cyber attaques sur les
bancs de données détenues par la cible
ou plus facilement au mieux encore sur
celle des sous traitants alors on parle
beaucoup des cyber attaques criminelles
qui demandent des rançons avait ces
histoires de ransomware mais on oublie
que les mêmes méthodes sont utilisées
pour détourner des données piratées des
brevets identifier les réseaux
commerciaux copier des fichiers ou
encore intercepté les échanges dans une
négociation ou dans une discussion qui
est sûr c'est que mené depuis des pays
étrangers utilisant les relais fournis
par des vagues d'ordinateurs a servi
vous savez que un premier ordinateur en
pollue un second puis le second un
troisième est que tout se mette à obéir
au premier ce qui permet d'éviter les
poursuites judiciaires en étant très
difficilement identifiable à la moyenne
actuelle c'est de l'ordre de 3 au dessus
de trois relais successifs
c'est très difficile d'identifier
l'origine réelle de l'attak
alors ces espions industriels ceux
qu'utilisent ces techniques là peuvent
être des services de renseignement
d'état les groupes criminels des
entreprises ou encore des sociétés
spécialisées auxquelles on va sous
traiter ces missions est légal
tous sans exception doivent connaître
parfaitement l'adversaire et son
environnement
avant d'opérer pour l'heure piraté de
l'année utile il faut être conscient que
dans la guerre économique actuel la
stratégie de conquête de marchés à
l'exportation s'appuie pour certains
pays mais aussi pour de nombreux groupes
industriels sur une politique offensive
de pillages à leur profit de fleurons du
secteur stratégique
on va chercher chez les autres ce qu'il
manque chez soi et pour cela
on utilise des administrations des
entreprises des cabinets de conseil et
même des ong
je dirais même de plus en plus des eaux
à nu elles vont être coordonnées pour
récupérer des opérations utiles sans
bien sûr se dévoiler et en france pour
citer notre pays
on a vu ces méthodes qui mélange
l'intelligence économique la partie
légale et l'espionnage industriel
la partie légale appliqués sur des
groupes de très grands groupes comme
airbus qui vient plus ou moins de s'en
sortir
technip qui a été absorbée par une
société américaine où elle somme dont
tout le monde connaît l'histoire mais en
réalité ce phénomène il est mondial on
le retrouve partout
certains pays sont réputés disposer de
capacités d'espionnage économique et
parmi les principaux acteurs
il est vrai que la première puissance
mondiale celle qui fait la course en
tête ce sont les américains qui
concentre depuis le président bush
président bush père
plus de 50% des activités de leurs
services à la recherche de
renseignements économiques
par ailleurs il mobilise officiellement
tous les moyens de l'état pour appuyer
leurs principales entreprises dans la
compétition internationale à travers ce
qui s'appelle l'advocacy center alors
l'advocacy centers un service du
département du commerce qui a été créée
et est déjà pas mal d'années par le
président bill clinton et qui regroupe
toutes les informations et atic venant
donc de toutes les administrations
américaines pour aider à la réalisation
des 120 plus gros contrats négociés
chaque année par les américains hors de
chez eux les américains exploite aussi
les échanges d'informations chez leurs
alliés comme chez leurs ennemis pour les
utiliser à leur profit sous le prétexte
discutable de surveiller la corruption
la compliance où le respect des lois
extraterritoriales qu'on a pu le voir
dans des affaires récentes dans la
sphère huawei dont on parle maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois
il est indiscutable que la campagne de
pressions et de menaces variés vise en
réalité à donner le temps aux
entreprises américaines de rattraper
leur retard dans l'ain 5 g par rapport
aux chinois il faut bien comprendre que
la haine et c'est comme l'a expliqué
edward snowdon dans son livre récent qui
vient de paraître a mis en place avec le
réseau five i'll ce que d'autres
appellent échelon un système
d'interception une surveillance mondiale
qui s'appuie sur la 3g et la 4g
on comprend pourquoi l'année ça ne veut
pas voir remplacer son système par un
système chinois
le problème pour les européens est donc
de savoir par qui ils préfèrent est très
goûté à moins qu'il se décide à
promouvoir des solutions locales et nous
en avons une avec nokia ericsson qui
sont en avance par rapport aux
américains sur la 5g même s'ils sont en
retard par rapport aux chinois
l'espionnage d'état au service des
entreprises est aussi une
caractéristique forte de l'état chinois
depuis 2013
donc c'est pas d'aujourd'hui nous savons
grâce à mendiante qui est une entreprise
de cybersécurité américaine que l'unité
61 1398 du 3e département de l'état
major général chinois pratiquent le
cyber-espionnage à grande échelle à
l'époque à partir de son siège à
shanghai elle avait en six ans espionner
cent quarante et une entreprise
essentiellement anglo saxonne dans vingt
secteurs d'activité pendant une durée
moyenne de 356 jours ce qui est très
intéressant ça veut dire qu'ils sont
restés chez la cible pendant
pratiquement une année sans qu'on les
repère et nul doute qu'elle en fait
beaucoup plus aujourd'hui et complète
ainsi l'action du goyen bull services
secrets chinois
israël est évidemment est également
connu pour ses capacités offensives et
défensives à travers de certaines des
1000 start up qui sont issus de l'unité
militaire 8200 qui est spécialisé dans
le cyberespace et travaille en étroite
liaison avec l'université ben gourion à
beersheva qui vient de fêter son
anniversaire il ya quelques jours ces
cyber entreprise réputée performante et
agressives sont souvent sous traitante
de clients et d'états étrangers et la
france là dedans alors la france elle
est souvent citée la dgse la direction
générale de la sécurité extérieure
française est souvent cité par les
américains et par wikileaks comme
performante dans ce domaine mais peu
d'informations sont sorties dans les
médias sur les actions menées à
l'extérieur
peut-être parce qu'ils sont très
efficaces et en tout cas il est certain
que une des rares fois on a eu une
information intéressante
ça a été il ya une dizaine d'années où
on a appris qu'un logiciel de recherche
dénommé babar avait au début des années
80 fait toute une série de tentatives de
pénétration des entreprises américaines
il est sûr que la france est pénalisée
par rapport à d'autre part le faible
niveau de coopération entre le public et
le privé parce que ça pénalise
l'efficacité des échanges c'est pénalise
la possibilité de se comprendre et se
renforcer et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
peut dire que c'est la grande différence
avec les anglais qui viennent d'annoncer
la création d'un service spécialisé dans
les attaques informatiques en tout genre
dont que ils ont carrément annoncé ce
qu'ils allaient faire clairement
enfin il faut pas oublier la russie qui
a été le champion indiscuté de
l'espionnage industriel par contact
direct dans les années 80 souvenons nous
de la faire farwell qui avait permis aux
français d'avoir la copie d'une grande
quantité de documents et de plans
récupérés par les services russes de
l'époque
or cette affaire faisait suite aux
affaires du concorde et de dassault
vingt ans plus tôt dans lesquelles les
plans d'une partie des avions avaient
été copiés et utilisé par les
soviétiques
aujourd'hui au delà des actions directes
du svr le service des renseignements
extérieurs de la fédération de russie
les cyberattaques pour ce qu'on en sait
sont généralement menées par des groupes
de hackers soupçonnés d'être proches du
renseignement russes comme par exemple
fanci birou cosy bear est une de ces
deux entités auraient servi sous
traitants si vous en souvenez il ya
quelques temps à des shs dans l' attaque
de tv5 monde c'était en avril 2015 et
elle s'est traduite par la destruction
du matériel un arrêt de la diffusion et
de la publication des informations sur
cette chaîne
et puis un message de soutien à l'état
islamique qui était paru sur tous les
écrans
pour se défendre face à cette réalité
toujours mais qui est aussi très moderne
il faut faire de l'information de la
sensibilisation du contrôle et de la
répression
et ces quatre éléments en france bien
vous avez différentes administrations
qui le font et en particulier elle se
charge de collecter toutes les
informations utiles pour en informer les
entreprises et ceux chargés de lutter
contre l'espionnage industriel dont il
ya un travail global est un travail de
chacune des entités la sécurité décide
du personnel elle est assurée par des
sociétés spécialisées ou des directions
sûreté qui mettent en place des systèmes
de production spécifique au niveau
extérieur et intérieur
mais ceci impose au préalable d'avoir
défini très exactement le niveau de
confidentialité requis pour tous les
types d'information existant dans
l'entreprise c'est un exercice difficile
dans la mesure où il s'agit de définir
très précisément ce qui est important
est moins important ce qui doit rester
secret et ce qui l'est moins
l'autre volet c'est la sensibilisation
indispensable de l'encadrement et du
personnel tout comme le suivi des
affaires après alerte parce qu'il faut
faire un retour d'expérience après
chacun des problèmes et ils sont faits
en général par l'ancienne direction
centrale du renseignement intérieur qui
est devenue la dgs i ils sont fait
également pour les unités de défense les
sociétés de défense par la direction du
renseignement et de la sécurité de la
défense
et bien sûr pour tout le monde parle
agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information au niveau de
l'état et des entreprises qu'on appelle
l'ansi et qui est maintenant reconnue au
niveau mondial comme une des plus
efficaces dans son domaine il est
certain qu'au delà des lois
traditionnelles contre la pratique
classique de l'espionnage civils et
militaires qui existe depuis fort
longtemps la france a besoin dorénavant
de loi adapté aux réalités d'aujourd'hui
parce que le risque majeur
il est passé d éléments matériels aux
éléments immatériels ou intangible avec
la numérisation la protection du
cyber-espace étatiques ou industrielle
est donc devenue prioritaire compte tenu
des enjeux et compte tenu des risques
multiples qu'ils génèrent dans tous les
aspects de la finance à la sécurité des
brevets c'est pourquoi on est frappé par
la naïveté des personnels et
d'encadrement face à ce type de
pratiques
si les administrations s'organise de
mieux en mieux les collectivités restent
fragiles et les pme pmi ne sont pas
suffisamment armés tandis que les grands
groupes semblent encore vulnérable et on
le constate en voyant que la plupart de
leurs dirigeants ont du mal à imaginer
que d'autres ne respectent pas leurs
règles du jeu dans le fond ils ne
comprennent pas parce que ce n'est pas
de leur monde qu'au delà des limites du
patriotisme économique
il existe sur la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez keek pour des
motifs divers et sans aucune hésitation
ni morale la fin justifie les moyens
à bientôt
[Musique]